- [Narrator] Are you facing
a challenging dilemma
in your life right now? The
Dilemma's a new Jubilee show
and we're looking for people
who are seeking advice,
willing to be vulnerable,
and anonymously sharing their
dilemmas on camera. Click
on the link in the description
below and share your dilemma.
- Oh, have that too.
- Let me just grab it up by the...
I don't know if this is kid-friendly.
(lively rhythmic music)
- [Host] We brought
together seven sex workers.
- I'm a sex worker.
- I am a sex worker.
- I'm a sex worker
- And I'm a sex worker.
- [Host] One of them is a virgin.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out?
- Everyone get naked.
(everyone laughs)
- What will that tell you about me?
- I guess who's more comfortable.
- What platforms do you guys use?
- I do porn on my OnlyFans.
- I do OnlyFans.
- Yeah, OnlyFans JustFor.Fans,
and I do in-person work as well.
- Okay.
- I actually don't use a platform.
I'm just a stripper and a sugar baby.
(Ashley laughs)
- [Ginny] Oh, okay.
- Like, she said she
didn't have an OnlyFans.
Like, I feel like every sex
worker that I've known at least,
like, uses OnlyFans in some regard.
Just OnlyFans. Yeah.
- I was a sugar baby for a brief period,
but since the pandemic,
OnlyFans was like popular,
so I hopped on the wave.
What's your guys' favorite part
about sex work?
- Money?
- Money.
- The only good part.
- I mean, I'm pretty promiscuous
in my real life, so I feel
like I'm just doing exactly
what I would be doing anyway.
- I like the creative side.
- I feel like I was sexual,
like, in the past, but
after like working in the sex
industry, I've become less.
I feel like your boundaries
have to be so important
- Even on OnlyFans. Like
even through online,
like, having that
relationship that's, like-
- What do you do on your OnlyFans?
- I used to do, like girl-girl,
but I've kind of transitioned
into like a softer core
because I'm actually on my way out.
I'm retiring this year
because I'm getting married.
Not that-I mean, you can
be married and do it.
- The comment about, like, getting married
kind of made no sense to me.
When I get married, I'm gonna
still hold a (beep) out.
- I wanted to think of like
something only people, like,
with an OnlyFans would know.
What happens when you block someone?
- You can choose whether or
not they still have access.
No. When they're blocked they're gone.
(everyone talking at once)
(bell rings)
- As a sex worker, everyone
kind of has a look.
He was the only one that didn't
have like a specific look.
- He was shuffling his feet.
I was shuffling my feet
because I'm anxious. But I was like, hmm.
- He just wasn't giving
me a sex worker vibe.
(buzzer sounding)
- Bye.
- Bye, Jay.
- Sorry.
- I didn't suspect Jay at all
because, like, look at that
guy. He obviously (bleep).
- Yeah, I was, I mean,
I was kind of surprised,
but I guess I was pretty quiet.
I didn't really say too much, so...
- Currently I do like different,
like, themes and stuff like that.
because I like to dress up.
So, this is a cow.
- Ooh, okay.
- Obviously one of my favorites.
And then I have the
sequin shorts that I wear,
like, to start off with, but
they don't stay on for long.
- When he brought out the
cow costume, I was like,
"What is he-what is he gonna
do in the cow costume?"
- Like, does he moo, or
(bleep) himself off in it?
Or like, what are you actually
doing in that costume?
- So I brought my favorite
pair of stripper heels.
I love wearing white heels at work
because there's, like, the
blue lights and everything,
so they just like glow different.
- Like, reflect.
- Yeah.
- Okay. I brought my trans erotica award.
I was the best trans man performer.
(applause)
- How much did that cost to
get commissioned on Etsy?
Just Kidding.
- Right, I did that just for this.
- I have that, too.
- Let me just grab it up
by the, but this is pretty.
I don't know if this is kid-friendly.
I don't know if it's that
much better, honestly, but
- It's like way worse.
- It's a speculum.
I do a lot of like kink play.
- I kind of have like the
OnlyFans, like, grab-bag.
This is, like, my browser's bag.
This is a lube shooter.
This is my first ever,
like, cause I'm Asian-la, la la.
This is my first ever, like,
outfit that I, like, wore.
This is a ring light, the necessities.
This is a porn hum slipper
because you need to be cozy.
And this is like, you know, like,
what I wear on a Saturday night for fun.
- [Ginny] (indistinct)
- [Kazumi] Yeah. Obvious.
- I brought my birth
control, 'cause I was like,
I'm obviously not a virgin.
- She brought birth
control and I was like,
anybody could have birth control.
I had birth control when I was, like, 14.
So I don't know that
that, like, convinced me.
- So birth control is like the
one thing you can't be like,
"I had sex."
- Took birth control control for my acne.
- You could have menstrual
issues and use it for that.
- I'm a doctor. I have a speculum.
- Oh, true.
- Yeah. There's a lot of like help.
- I didn't really think about that.
(Stevie laughs)
- How did I get started?
- I actually didn't get
started in the best way.
I was like kind of groomed into it.
I was 17 when I started
doing full-service sex work.
I was a homeless youth
and that was pretty much
the only way that I could
make money enough to, like,
support myself. And then
obviously that was dangerous.
And so... Yeah, then I started to do it
on the OnlyFans, and then I
got addicted to fast money.
- Yeah. I was kind of
surrounded by other sex workers
and was trying to start a
freelance writing career
that was not going very well.
(laughter)
So I was like, "All right,
I'm gonna try to make a
little coin on the side."
And then I started picking
up some studio work,
and started making my own stuff, and
Yeah, that's how I got started.
And now I do that, instead.
(funky music)
(participants exclaim)
- I'm 0.2 on only fans.
I make over six figures.
I do it only for the money. I hate men.
I literally think I'm
becoming more attracted
to women because of my job.
- So I got started
stripping when I was 19.
I saw an ad on Instagram that
they were looking for people
and I was like, "Oh (beep) yeah."
And I had been a competitive
dancer my whole life,
so it was like, made sense to do it.
And then I started working
at a different club.
And then at that club I met my sugar
daddy who I've had for
like almost four years now.
- Yeah. I started, oh,
when I was like, what, 21?
I was actually working
at a sex club in DC.
I was a receptionist and the
guy would come all the time
and he would ask me things
like when you come in and sleep
with me and then I was just
like, you got some money?
So I started with that, but I
really do wanna get the money
so I can get my production
company started,
and have a gay sex shop.
(intense rhythmic music)
(buzzer sounding)
- Okay.
- I love you though.
- It's okay.
- I do want to watch your show.
- I want to watch your gay sex show.
- Bye.
I was like, "Why would
y'all think I'm a virgin?"
Like, do I look like a virgin?
- I just wanted to, like, go back
to the previous conversation
because we don't have a lot
of representation as sex workers.
So I try to stray away from
saying things like fast money
or easy money because a lot of the times
people will be like, oh, see,
like they're just woke up
and they just made money.
- [Ginny] It's not easy.
- And it's really hard.
- It's like irritating
when people are like, "Oh
I should just do an only fan
so I can make hella money too."
Like, it's not that easy.
- It's definitely a grind. But
I think that it is different
in a way that like, I don't know.
I was able in my first
month to make $25,000,
which like is just like not a normal-
- True.
- It's such a small
percentage of people who
are gonna make that easy money.
- Yeah.
- Even me, as a trans
man, I don't make a ton
of money compared to what
other people do, but...
- We do sacrifices and we put ourselves
in compromising positions sometimes.
And that's why we make a
lot of money, especially
because the social stigma
makes it dangerous.
- There's a lot of us.
- Totally. Thank you.
- For sure.
So when did everyone lose their virginity?
- So, I hope my mom isn't watching this,
but I was 13 and I was-
- Oh!
- Right? It was so young.
I was dating this guy
for a few months and
we decided to have sex.
It was with a banana flavored condom,
like, in his like dirty
bed, like rushed before it-
- [Kazumi] W`as he also 13?
- He was also 13. Yeah.
- Okay.
- Oh, banana condom makes more sense.
I think virginity is actually a construct.
I think that virginity was
created by men who think
that a penis can change the
chemistry of a woman's body.
But I lost my virginity at
16 and I had blood streaming.
It's a horror story.
- I wouldn't say I was like
super religious growing up,
but I kind of had like some
reservations about penis
and vagina sex for a while.
So in high school I did
the poop hole loophole
so I didn't go to hell.
(Ashley laughs)
- Oh my God, that's kinda sexy.
- I grew up super religiously too.
- I was actually a Jehovah's witness.
- Wow.
- And I was gonna save
myself until marriage.
I can't even for begin to
imagine that now, but I was 17.
Like it, like, happened enough to say
that I lost my virginity, but
I wouldn't say like I had sex.
You know what I mean? Like
- Virginity is a construct, like, yeah.
- Like it kinda happened, but...
Okay, Wait, I have a question:
Is water a good lube?
- No.
- [Stevie] Water?
- Water. I mean spit? like
water-based lube? Yes.
- A water based lube. Yes, please.
- I was just looking for the virgin.
- Oh my God.
- Oh, like shower sex.
- I've like had so much
awful sex in a jacuzzi.
- It's the worst.
- It's giving UTI.
- Yeah. It's giving UTI.
It's giving uncomfy.
It's giving like why is this
so wet and dry at the same?
- Yeah.
(bell rings)
- She was really timid, and
again with the OnlyFans thing.
- I heard Jehovah's witness
and my ears perked up.
(buzzer sounding)
- Bye, I love you.
- Bye.
- Sorry.
- I'm so sorry. I love you.
- Ginny was just the
last person that I had
the little tiniest bit of suspicion about.
- Oh, wait.
- What do your parents think?
- My dad kind of, I have a really
like, weird relationship
with both my parents.
My mom doesn't know, but I feel
like she knows my dad doesn't know
but I feel like he knows.
I live with my dad.
So he's, like, probably
wondering, like, why
I have so much free time.
- And is he Jehovah's witness still?
- No, my dad was never, my mom was.
And I used to live with
her and I moved out.
- Yeah. I'm not super
close with my family.
I'm totally proud of the work
that I do. I'll tell anybody.
I'll tell anybody all day long,
but I'm not close with my family.
So it's just not the kind of
information I feel safe sharing
with them. I don't think that they would-
- I respect that.
- support it necessarily.
- Like, it's not
necessarily the work itself,
especially since I'm an online
sex worker, that's dangerous.
It's more like the social stigma
from people who, you know,
want to commit violence
because I choose what I do.
But it's like my actual day-to-day.
Like I love my customers.
I love men, you know?
Ooh, controversial.
But like I like love guys and
I like making them feel good.
You know, my supporters, like
I really appreciate them,
but sex work can be dangerous
because of the way people perceive us.
(bell rings)
- The fact that she said she'd
been a Jehovah's witness.
It was just a possibility
that maybe she was a virgin.
- I was kind of listening
to like the marker.
And I could hear that
everyone wrote my name down.
So then I just wrote Kazumi down.
(buzzer sounding)
- Sorry.
- Bye Ginny. You're beautiful.
(intense music playing)
(cheering)
- That was too easy.
- I was pretty confident that, you know,
a couple of hookers could
sniff out who the virgin was.
- Are you still gonna have a gay show?
- No, it was all a lie.
- What?
- It was all a lie. It was all a lie.
- Was just like a Halloween costume, huh?
- Yeah, it was a Halloween costume
- I knew it.
- Yeah it was a Halloween costume.
- Can we ask why you're a
virgin? Is it like a choice?
- No, it's not interesting or anything.
I'm not waiting until like
marriage or anything like that.
I'm just like really, I don't know.
I wasn't introduced to
sex like at all, really,
like until like, college, but yeah.
Not, until marriage or anything just
to when I meet the right guy.
So if he's watching, call me.
- To be a sex worker means
being a small business owner.
It means being a content
creator and an entrepreneur.
I sell a product just
like many other people do.
It just happens to be that my
product is sex and my body.
- I did misspeak when I
said that it was fast money.
I think it is like a
ridiculous amount of money.
Very, very fast.
But it's definitely at
the cost of other things.
I don't want to go too deep,
but I think that there's like
a deep sadness.
Like not, not all of us are
like so happy to be sex workers.
It was sort of a necessity to bring me
out of like a pretty bad place.
- There are a million other
girls who are just as hot horny
and ready to do it as me,
and they're not making the
same amount of money as me
because they're not doing what I'm doing.
Why can't sluts change the world.
- That's a stack.
- You got one wrong so
I'm just going to go ahead
and cut it in half.
- Wow.
- In half?
- You get some.
- Everybody gets a stack.
(laughter)
- Yay. I can't dance.